willkommen zurück bei Quantum Computing in der Praxis, ich bin Olivia Lan, und die heutige Folge drei dreht sich um ein
QAOA-Experiment im Utility-Maßstab. Wenn du von Anfang an dabei warst, hast du gesehen, wie wir uns durch
IBM Quantum Hardware, das Framework der Qiskit-Patterns und die neuesten und besten Fehlerminderungstechniken gearbeitet haben, die
Forschende und Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler einsetzen, um Quantum circuits zu skalieren. Wir fanden es wirklich wichtig, euch all diesen
Kontext zu vermitteln und euch die Richtung zu zeigen, in die wir uns bewegen. Aber jetzt gibt es keinen Grund mehr, länger zu warten und all diese Informationen in
Aktion zu sehen. Einige Dinge solltest du im Hinterkopf behalten, bevor wir anfangen: Alles folgt dem Framework von Qiskit
Patterns, also gehen wir diese Schritte der Reihe nach durch: Erstens das Problem auf den circuit abbilden, zweitens den circuit optimieren, drittens
mit Primitives ausführen und viertens die Ergebnisse nachverarbeiten bzw. analysieren. Wir beginnen mit einem recht kleinen Beispiel,
damit ihr ein gutes Gefühl für diese Schritte und ihren Zweck bekommt. Danach besprechen wir ein sehr ähnliches, aber deutlich
größeres Beispiel, um zu zeigen, wie man das Problem auf die 100-qubit-Ebene skalieren würde. Ich werde euch alle
Werkzeuge an die Hand geben, damit ihr nach dieser Vorlesung dieses Problem eigenständig ausführen könnt. Zuletzt: Das hier wird kein
Code-Walkthrough sein. So sehr wir uns das auch wünschen – Code wird mit der Zeit alt und veraltet. Wenn du also dieses Video
ein Jahr nach seiner Veröffentlichung schaust, möchte ich nicht, dass du dich an der Syntax aufhängst, die sich im Laufe der Zeit leicht ändern kann. Stattdessen wird dies eine
ausführliche Diskussion der Logik und des Problemansatzes sein. Es gibt jedoch ein Notebook-Tutorial, das zu diesem
Video gehört und in der Beschreibung unten verlinkt ist. Den Code parallel durchzugehen oder nach dem
Anschauen dieser Lektion darauf zurückzugreifen und ihn selbst auszuführen, wird dir das bestmögliche Lernerlebnis bieten. Zur kurzen Erinnerung: Nicht
alle Rechenprobleme eignen sich für Quantum Computing. Einfache Probleme und simple Berechnungen müssen diese
Technologie nicht nutzen, denn klassische Computer lösen sie bereits problemlos. Stand 2024 sind die
drei Bereiche, bei denen wir am optimistischsten sind, diese: Natur simulieren, Daten mit komplexer
Struktur verarbeiten und schließlich Optimierung. Optimierungsprobleme zählen zu den schwierigsten Rechenproblemen,
die effizient zu lösen sind. Bei einem Optimierungsproblem sucht man nach dem größten oder kleinsten möglichen Wert
einer gegebenen Kostenfunktion. Bei vielen interessanten Problemen wird das Finden dieses Extremums jedoch exponentiell
schwieriger, je größer das Problem wird. Deshalb wird die Berechnung so komplex. Als Beispiel kannst du dir vorstellen, wie
schwierig es ist, optimale Flugrouten oder Lieferwege quer durchs Land zu berechnen. In dieser Lektion werden wir
ein bestimmtes Optimierungsproblem namens Max Cut untersuchen, das wir mithilfe eines Quantum-
Algorithmus namens Quantum Approximation Optimization Algorithm – kurz QAOA – lösen werden. Was ist also das Max-Cut-Problem? Ein
Maximum-Cut-Problem ist eine Art kombinatorisches Optimierungsproblem, das auf einem Graphen definiert ist. Das Ziel besteht darin,
die Knoten des Graphen in zwei Teilmengen aufzuteilen, sodass die Anzahl der Kanten zwischen den beiden Teilmengen
maximiert wird. In diesem Graphen hier ist jeder Knoten wie gezeigt verbunden, und der Max Cut wird durch diese geschwungene
Linie dargestellt, die die Knoten in die lila Gruppe und die graue Gruppe unterteilt. Um dies zu erreichen, indem man die größtmögliche
Anzahl an Kanten schneidet, muss man in diesem Graphen fünf Kanten durchtrennen. Da der Graph so klein ist,
ist es nicht schwer, ein paar mögliche Schnitte auf Papier oder sogar im Kopf auszuprobieren und herauszufinden, dass fünf die bestmögliche
Option ist. Stell dir aber vor, die Anzahl der Knoten verdoppelt sich und verdreifacht sich dann – das wird schnell unmöglich, von
Hand zu lösen, und ab einer bestimmten Anzahl wird es so knifflig, dass selbst Supercomputer Schwierigkeiten haben, zuverlässig die beste Antwort zu liefern. Das liegt daran,
dass die maximale Anzahl an Schnitten exponentiell mit der Anzahl der Knoten wächst. Auch wenn das etwas abstrakt klingen mag:
Es gibt viele reale Probleme, die sich auf ein Max-Cut-Problem zurückführen lassen – etwa Betrugserkennung im Finanzwesen, Graph-
Clustering, Netzwerkdesign, VLSI-Design sowie Social-Media-Analyse. Das
Social-Media-Beispiel ist besonders leicht zu verstehen. Angenommen, du möchtest eine Gruppe von Personen finden, die die meisten möglichen
Verbindungen zu anderen Personen auf einer Social-Media-Plattform haben, um Power-User zu identifizieren – also Leute, die
den größten Einfluss in einer Gruppe ausüben. Unternehmen versuchen das tatsächlich sehr häufig. Ein letzter Punkt: Max Cut ist oft
eine Unterroutine eines größeren Problems. Es definiert also möglicherweise nicht die eigentliche Anwendung, wird aber im Hintergrund verwendet. Es ist
viel häufiger anzutreffen, als man zunächst denken würde. Jetzt ist es Zeit, loszulegen. Der
erste Schritt besteht darin, unseren Graphen zu erstellen. Das kannst du tun, indem du ein Python-Paket namens rustworks importierst. Lege fest, wie
viele Knoten du verwendest, indem du die Zahl n angibst, und füge dann deine Knoten dem Graphen G hinzu. Du musst auch
deine Kanten definieren. Das machen wir hier von Hand, indem wir sie einfach in einem Array auflistest – so wie hier, wobei du die letzte
Zahl angibst, die das Gewicht der Kante bestimmt – also wie stark die beiden angegebenen Knoten miteinander verbunden sind. Hier bleiben wir
für alle Kanten bei einem Gewicht von eins, aber vielleicht macht es Spaß, später mit dem Gewicht zu experimentieren und zu sehen, wie sich die Lösung
verändert. Um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was Gewicht in diesem Zusammenhang bedeutet, kehren wir zu unserem Social-Media-Beispiel zurück. Du kannst dir
dieses Gewicht vorstellen als den Einfluss, den eine Person auf eine andere haben könnte. Die Verbindung zu deinem Partner oder einem Verwandten
würde beispielsweise wahrscheinlich ein höheres Gewicht erhalten als die zu jemandem, der nur eine flüchtige Bekanntschaft ist. Zeichne nun deinen Graphen. Das
angehängte Tutorial zeigt dir die richtige Syntax. Bevor wir überlegen, wie man das Problem auf einen Quantum circuit
abbildet, wollen wir zunächst verstehen, wie das Max-Cut-Problem überhaupt zu einem Optimierungsproblem wird.
Wir beginnen damit, die Minimierung einer Funktion f(x) zu betrachten, wobei die Eingabe x ein
n-dimensionaler Vektor ist, dessen Komponenten den einzelnen Knoten des Graphen entsprechen. Diese Funktion werden wir von nun an
als unsere Kostenfunktion bezeichnen. Dann müssen wir jede dieser Komponenten auf entweder null oder
eins einschränken – d. h. auf eine Seite des Schnitts oder die andere. Wir können eine Funktion schreiben als
ein Paar von Knoten x_i und x_j, das angibt, ob die entsprechende Kante im Schnitt liegt. Damit gilt: die Größe x_i + x_j
minus x_i mal x_j zeigt an, ob die Kante im Schnitt liegt. Ist dieser Ausdruck gleich
eins, bedeutet das, dass die Kante im Schnitt liegt; andernfalls ist er null und die Kante liegt nicht darin. Das Problem, die
maximale Anzahl von Kanten im Schnitt zu finden, lässt sich dann als Maximierung dieser Funktion formulieren. Als nächstes werden wir
ein globales Minuszeichen vor diese Funktion setzen, sodass das neue Problem äquivalent dazu ist, das Minimum dieser Funktion
zu finden. Das Minimum von f(x) liegt in diesem Fall dann vor, wenn die Anzahl der vom Schnitt durchquerten Kanten
maximal ist. Wir wählen diese Formulierung als Minimierungsproblem, weil wir es dadurch später auf ein Energie-
minimierungsproblem abbilden können – also auf das Finden des Grundzustands –, worin Quantencomputer von Natur aus besonders gut sind.
Aber denk daran: Bisher hat das noch nichts mit Quantum Computing zu tun. Wir müssen dieses Problem immer noch in
etwas umformulieren, das ein Quantencomputer verstehen kann. Jetzt sind wir bereit, uns richtig reinzuknien und die Arbeit zu beginnen. Der
erste Schritt besteht darin, das Problem auf einen Quantum circuit abzubilden. Es ist vielleicht nicht offensichtlich, wie wir
werden wir von einem Graphen wie dem, den wir gerade gezeichnet haben, zu einem Quantum circuit übergehen, aber lass uns das langsam angehen – denk daran, wir sind
dabei, dieses Max-Cut-Problem mit QAOA zu lösen. Im QAOA-Algorithmus möchten wir letztendlich einen Operator haben,
den Hamiltonian, der verwendet wird, um die Kostenfunktion unseres Problems darzustellen, sowie einen parametrisierten
circuit – den Ansatz oder den Testzustand –, den wir verwenden werden, um Quantenzustände darzustellen, die fundierte Vermutungen oder Kandidaten sind
für die Lösung des Problems. Wir können aus diesen Kandidatenzuständen sampeln und sie dann auswerten
mithilfe der Kostenfunktion. In diesem Fall ist die Kostenfunktion f(x), aber wir müssen sie auf eine
Weise ausdrücken, die sich für den Quantencomputer natürlich anfühlt. Dafür nutzen wir eine Reihe mathematischer
Transformationen, um f(x) als Energiefunktion – den Hamiltonian – auszudrücken. Der erste Schritt des
Prozesses besteht darin, das Problem der Minimierung von f(x) als quadratische uneingeschränkte binäre Optimierung
(QUBO) auszudrücken. QUBO ist eine allgemeine Methode, um diese kombinatorischen Optimierungsprobleme zu formulieren.
Hier ist Q eine N×N-Matrix reeller Zahlen. N entspricht der Anzahl der
Knoten in unserem Graphen – fünf für dieses Beispiel –, und X ist derselbe Vektor binärer Variablen aus der ursprünglichen
Formulierung. Um den QAOA-Algorithmus effektiv auszuführen, müssen wir unser Optimierungsproblem in Form eines
Hamiltonians ausdrücken, der ein mathematischer Operator ist, der die Gesamtenergie eines Systems darstellt. Konkret möchten wir
einen Kostenfunktions-Hamiltonian erstellen, der die Eigenschaft hat, dass sein Grundzustandenergie- oder Minimum-Eigenwert
dem Minimum der Funktion entspricht, die die maximale Anzahl von Schnitten im Graphen G kodiert. Sobald wir
diesen Hamiltonian haben, müssen wir zur Lösung unseres Optimierungsproblems nur noch den Grundzustand des Hamiltonians auf dem Quantencomputer vorbereiten, dann
wird das Sampeln aus diesem Zustand mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit die Lösung der Minimierung von f(x) liefern. Wie sich
herausstellt, haben wir Glück, denn das QUBO-Problem ist sehr eng verwandt mit und tatsächlich rechnerisch äquivalent zu
einem der bekanntesten und allgegenwärtigsten Hamiltonians in der Physik: dem Ising-Hamiltonian. Um das QUBO-
Problem als diesen Ising-Hamiltonian zu schreiben, müssen wir eigentlich nur eine einfache Variablensubstitution vornehmen, um von
booleschen Variablen 0 und 1 zu Spinvariablen minus eins und eins überzugehen. Dieser Schritt ist
unkompliziert und wird im Anhang des beigefügten Notebooks für Interessierte ausführlicher gezeigt. Am Ende ist aber die Minimierung dieses QUBO-
Ausdrucks dieselbe wie die Minimierung dieses Ausdrucks. Nochmals leicht umgeschrieben und
wir haben unseren Kostenfunktions-Hamiltonian, bei dem das Minimum des Ausdrucks den Grundzustand darstellt, und Z
wird zum Pauli-Z-Operator, während B ein reeller skalarer Koeffizient ist. Nun, da wir unseren Hamil-
tonian haben, lässt er sich unkompliziert in Form von zwei lokalen ZZ-Pauli-Operatoren umschreiben, die sich leicht in
zwei kubische gates in unserem Quantum circuit umwandeln lassen. Bitte schau dir das zugehörige Notebook an, um zu sehen, wie das gemacht wird, aber die Ausgabe
ist durch diese Zeile hier gegeben. Beachte, dass es in unserem Beispiel
sechs Objekte oder Pauli-Strings gibt, da jeder eine Kante im Graphen repräsentiert. Die Länge des Strings entspricht der Anzahl
der Knoten, also ist I I I ZZ für fünf Knoten, und der String besteht aus
Identitäten an allen Positionen, außer an den Indizes der Knoten, die an einer Kante beteiligt sind, welche Z-Terme haben. In Qiskit
werden bit strings, die qubits repräsentieren, rückwärts indiziert. Eine Kante zwischen den Knoten 0 und 1 wird zum Beispiel kodiert als
I I I ZZ. Mit dem in Form von Paulis geschriebenen Hamiltonian sind wir bereit, unseren
Quantum circuit zu konstruieren. Dieser Quantum circuit wird uns helfen, gute Lösungen vom Quantencomputer zu sampeln. Der QAOA-Algorithmus
ist vom adiabatischen Theorem inspiriert, das besagt, dass wenn wir im Grundzustand des zeitabhängigen
Hamiltonians starten und sich der Hamiltonian langsam genug entwickelt und genug Zeit gegeben wird, der Endzustand der Grundzustand
des endgültigen Hamiltonians sein wird. QAOA kann als die diskrete Trotter-Version des Quanten-
adiabatischen Algorithmus betrachtet werden, bei dem jeder Trotter-Schritt eine Schicht darstellt, die wir P nennen werden. Also
anstatt in jeder Schicht P von einem Zustand zum anderen zu entwickeln, werden wir zwischen unserem Kostenfunktions-
Hamiltonian und dem sogenannten Mixer-Hamiltonian hin- und herwechseln, über den wir gleich mehr hören werden. Der Punkt, den ich machen möchte,
ist, dass QAOA den Vorteil hat, schneller als der Quanten-adiabatische Algorithmus zu sein, aber er liefert ungefähre
Lösungen statt der optimalen. Im Grenzwert, wo die Anzahl der Schichten gegen Unendlich geht, konvergiert QAOA zum adiabatischen
Fall, aber das ist natürlich rechnerisch sehr aufwendig. Um unseren Quantum circuit zu erstellen,
wenden wir abwechselnde Operatoren an, hier parametrisiert durch gamma und beta, die
die Diskretisierung der Zeitentwicklung darstellen. Die drei Hauptteile
des QAOA circuit sind also: erstens der anfängliche Testzustand in Grau, der der Grundzustand
des Mixers aus dem adiabatischen Zustand der Evolution ist, erstellt durch Anwenden eines Hadamard gate auf jeden qubit; zweitens
die Kostenfunktionsentwicklung, die wir bereits in Dunkelviolett haben; und drittens die Entwicklung unter dem Mixer-
Hamiltonian, den wir noch nicht in Hellviolett besprochen haben. Unser Start-Hamiltonian wird
Mixer genannt, weil sein Grundzustand die Superposition aller möglichen bit strings von Interesse ist und damit
am Anfang eine Mischung aller möglichen Lösungen erzwingt. Der Mixer-Hamiltonian ist die einfache Summe der Pauli-X-
Operationen auf jedem Knoten des Graphen. Qiskit erlaubt dir, einen anderen benutzerdefinierten Mixer-Operator zu verwenden, wenn du möchtest, aber
für diesen Fall verwenden wir einfach den Standard. Du siehst also wieder, dass mit Qiskit ein Großteil der Arbeit
für uns erledigt wird, wodurch das Ermitteln des Mixer-Hamiltonians und des Startzustands trivial wird. Die einzige Arbeit, die wir leisten mussten, war
die Kostenfunktion zu finden. Jede Iteration dieser Operatoren wird als Schicht bezeichnet. Diese Schichten können als
Diskretisierungen der Zeitentwicklung des Systems betrachtet werden, wie zuvor beschrieben. Das abwechselnde Muster kommt aus der
Trotter-Zerlegung und approximiert die Exponentialfunktionen nicht-kommutierender Matrizen. Im Allgemeinen gilt: je mehr Schichten oder
Schritte wir einbeziehen, desto näher kommen wir an die kontinuierliche Zeitentwicklung heran. Theoretisch wird das Ergebnis also genauer,
aber für dieses Beispiel beginnen wir einfach mit zwei Schichten. Denk daran: sowohl der Kostenfunktions-Hamiltonian als auch
der Mixer sind parametrisiert. Wir müssen noch optimale Werte für gamma und
beta finden. Ich weiß, das waren sehr viele Informationen, und wenn du diese Art von Mathematik zum ersten Mal siehst, kann das schwierig sein. Zum Glück ist eines der großartigen
Dinge an Qiskit, dass vieles von dem, was wir gerade durchgegangen sind, automatisch und ohne großen Aufwand für den Nutzer erledigt werden kann. Es ist gut zu verstehen, was
unter der Haube passiert, besonders wenn wir auf größere Experimente skalieren, aber du musst das alles nicht von Hand erledigen,
jedes einzelne Mal. Wir haben unser Problem jetzt auf einen Quantum circuit abgebildet. Es war ein bisschen Arbeit,
aber keine Sorge – es wird einfacher und intuitiver, je öfter du es machst. Jetzt sind wir bereit, zu Schritt zwei überzugehen:
unseren circuit für Hardware zu optimieren. Während der circuit, den wir gerade erstellt haben, recht einfach aussieht und
nützlich ist, um ein intuitives Verständnis aufzubauen, denk daran: der Quantenchip versteht nicht, was diese abstrahierte
Block müssen wir ihn in eine Reihe von Ein- und Zwei-qubit-Gates umwandeln, die nativ für die Hardware sind, und wenn ich
„nativ" sage, meine ich, dass er in das umstrukturiert wird, was direkt auf den qubits ausgeführt werden kann. Solche circuits sind
so zu verstehen, dass sie in der Instruction Set Architecture des backends geschrieben sind, die du möglicherweise als ISA-circuits abgekürzt siehst.
Das Qiskit-SDK-transpiler-Modul bietet eine Reihe von Transpilierungsdurchläufen, die
eine breite Palette von circuit-Transformationen durchführen können. Wir möchten sicherstellen, dass unser circuit für unseren
Zweck optimiert ist. Erinnere dich aus unserer vorherigen Lektion, dass der Transpilierungsprozess mehrere Schritte umfasst: das Abbilden der
qubits im circuit bzw. der Entscheidungsvariablen auf physische qubits auf dem Gerät, das Entfalten der Anweisungen im
Quantencircuit in die hardwarennativen Anweisungen, die das backend tatsächlich versteht, sowie das Routing von
qubits im circuit, die direkt miteinander interagieren, zu physischen qubits, die benachbart sind mit
einem anderen, und wie immer findest du weitere Details dazu in der Dokumentation.
Jetzt kommt ein aufregender Schritt, bei dem wir auswählen, auf welchem backend wir unseren circuit ausführen wollen. Das müssen wir
vor dem Transpilierungsschritt tun, weil der transpiler für verschiedene Prozessoren unterschiedlich optimiert. Das ist ein weiterer Grund, warum es
wichtig ist, dass Qiskit so vieles in dieser Phase automatisieren kann. Du möchtest deinen circuit nicht von Hand optimieren müssen,
was zwar möglich ist, aber manchmal knifflig und sehr zeitaufwändig ist – nur um dann festzustellen, dass du eigentlich ausführen möchtest
deinen circuit auf einem anderen Prozessor mit anderen Eigenschaften, und dann musst du die ganze Arbeit noch einmal machen. Übergib
dein backend der Wahl an die transpiler-Funktion und vergiss nicht, deinen Optimierungslevel anzugeben. Diesmal
habe ich Optimierungslevel drei gewählt, das ist das höchste und umfassendste Optimierungsniveau.
Und das war es tatsächlich für Schritt zwei. Mein circuit wurde automatisch transpiliert, und ich habe ihn hier gezeichnet, damit
du sehen kannst, wie er in Ein- und Zwei-qubit-Gates übersetzt wurde. Jetzt ist es Zeit für Schritt drei:
den circuit mit Qiskit-Primitives ausführen. Bis jetzt haben wir den circuit transpiliert und dabei die Parameter gamma und
beta unverändert gelassen, aber wir können den circuit nicht wirklich ausführen, ohne den Wert dieser Parameter anzugeben. Im QAOA-
Workflow werden die optimalen QAOA-Parameter in einer iterativen Optimierungsschleife gefunden, in der wir eine Reihe von circuit-
Auswertungen durchführen und einen klassischen Optimierer verwenden, um die optimalen beta- und gamma-Parameter zu finden. Wir müssen jedoch irgendwo
anfangen, also habe ich einige Anfangsschätzungen für Gamma 1, Gamma 2 und Beta 1, Beta 2 von Pi / 2 und Pi
implementiert. Ich möchte auch darauf hinweisen, dass wir einen Optimierer verwenden werden, um bessere Lösungen für gamma und beta zu finden.
Da ich vorerst nur zwei Schichten berechne, ist das alles, was ich brauche. Wenn du aber einen genaueren QAOA-circuit
erstellst, würdest du mehr Schichten einschließen und benötigst daher ein optimiertes gamma und beta für jede aufeinanderfolgende
Schicht. Lass uns jetzt kurz innehalten und uns unsere Optionen für die Primitives in Erinnerung rufen. Wir haben den Estimator und
den Sampler. Welchen glaubst du, werden wir für diese Art von Aufgabe verwenden? Nun, egal was du
geraten hast, du liegst eigentlich richtig: Wir werden sowohl den Estimator als auch den Sampler verwenden. Für die anfängliche Optimierung
Schleife benötigen wir den Estimator, aber wir werden den Sampler später verwenden, um die endgültige
Lösung auszulesen. Jetzt sind wir fast bereit, unseren Algorithmus auszuführen – ich verspreche es –, aber ganz kurz ist es wichtig zu beachten, dass du
deinen Job auf verschiedene Arten senden kannst, die als Ausführungsmodi bezeichnet werden. Erstens haben wir den Job-Modus: eine einzelne
Primitive-Anfrage des Estimators oder Samplers, die ohne einen Kontextmanager gestellt wird. Circuits und Eingaben werden als Primitive
Unified Blocks (PUBs) verpackt und als Ausführungsaufgabe auf dem Quanten-
computer übermittelt. Der Batch-Modus ist ein Multi-Job-Manager für die effiziente Ausführung eines Experiments, das aus einer Reihe
von unabhängigen Jobs besteht. Verwende den Batch-Modus, um mehrere Primitive-Jobs gleichzeitig einzureichen. Session-Modus: ein dediziertes
Fenster für die Ausführung eines Multi-Job-Workflows. Dies ermöglicht Premium-Nutzern, mit Variationsalgorithmen auf vorhersehbarere Weise zu experimentieren
und sogar mehrere Experimente gleichzeitig auszuführen, indem sie die Parallelität des
Stacks nutzen. Verwende Sessions für iterative Workflows und Experimente, die dedizierten Zugang erfordern. Für ein QAOA-Experiment wäre eine
Session eine gute Wahl, wenn du Zugang dazu hast, da du mehrere circuits für verschiedene Werte von beta
und gamma ausprobieren musst. Okay, lass uns jetzt zu unserem Optimierungsproblem zurückkehren. Wir haben bereits
die Kostenfunktion Hamiltonoperator HC definiert, und der vollständige Workflow ist folgender: Der QAOA-
Algorithmus beginnt damit, die qubits im Superpositionszustand zu initialisieren, und wendet dann den Unit-Operator mit P Schichten an.
Er initialisiert die gamma- und beta-Parameter und führt dann den circuit mit dem Estimator-Primitive aus. Sobald wir die
Erwartungswerte berechnet haben, verwenden wir einen SciPy-Optimierer namens COBYLA. COBYLA
optimiert die Kostenfunktion klassisch außerhalb der QPU. Sobald diese Werte von gamma und beta aktualisiert wurden,
wiederholen wir den Vorgang. Wir tun dies so lange, bis der Wert der Gesamtkostenfunktion konvergiert und den niedrigsten Wert erreicht hat.
Dann wählen wir die Werte von gamma und beta aus, die diesem niedrigen Kostenwert entsprechen, und führen den circuit ein letztes Mal aus,
jetzt mit dem Sampler. Das ist das Ergebnis, nachdem ich den COBYLA-Optimierer mit meinen anfänglichen Schätzungen ausgeführt habe. Hier siehst du,
dass der Wert der Kostenfunktion über die durchgeführten Iterationen zunächst etwas unregelmäßig ist und auf und ab geht, aber
sich dann auf einen niedrigen Wert einpendelt. Wir werden diese letzten gamma- und beta-Werte verwenden, die dem minimalen Kostenwert entsprechen,
um den circuit ein letztes Mal auszuführen und den Bit-String zu sampeln, der uns den maximalen
Schnitt liefert. Jetzt werden wir mit unseren optimierten Werten für die Gammas und Betas den circuit ein letztes Mal ausführen, um den besten
möglichen Bit-String mit dem Sampler zu finden. Ich habe die spezifischen Werte, die ich hier verwende, aufgelistet, aber denk daran: Wenn du es
selbst ausprobierst oder sogar nur das gleiche Tutorial-Notebook erneut ausführst, können sich diese Werte leicht ändern. Jetzt werden wir
unseren optimierten circuit mit diesen Werten ausführen und unsere Kandidatenlösung für unser Max-Cut-Problem finden. Falls du
Sessions verwendet hast, ist das nicht mehr nötig, da wir nur noch einen letzten Job ausführen. Jetzt werden wir uns endlich den
Nachverarbeitungsschritt und die Suche nach unserer endgültigen Lösung ansehen. Lass uns zunächst alle
möglichen Kombinationen von Knoten, die wir in Bit-Strings umgewandelt haben, als Histogramm darstellen. Du siehst sofort, dass
ich bei meiner Ausführung vier Lösungen gefunden und diese lila hervorgehoben habe, da sie wahrscheinlicher sind als jede andere Lösung.
Der höchste und damit wahrscheinlichste Bit-String ist 0 1 0 1. Bitte beachte die Reihenfolge der qubits
im Plot, sie ist umgekehrt. Wenn wir uns die wahrscheinlichste Lösung ansehen, stellen wir fest, dass die Knoten 0 und drei zusammen gruppiert sind,
und ähnliches gilt für die Knoten 1, 2 und vier. Wir können nun endlich die wahrscheinlichste
Bit-String-Lösung als Graph darstellen. Denk daran, dass der Bit-String einfach den Knotennummern entspricht und ob sie enthalten sind –
mit einer Eins markiert – oder nicht enthalten sind – mit einer Null markiert – in unserer Gruppierung. Wenn wir den Schnitt nun einzeichnen, können wir mit unseren Augen
die ungefähre Linie für den besten Schnitt erkennen, die einfach die ideale Gruppierung aller fünf Knoten darstellt und die ich hier eingezeichnet habe.
Etwas, worüber ich hier jedoch einige Zeit sprechen möchte, ist die Tatsache, dass die richtige Lösung nicht eindeutig ist.
wegen der Symmetrie dieses Graphen gibt es mehrere korrekte Lösungen, anstatt dass die Knoten 0 und 3
innerhalb des Schnitts liegen, könnten stattdessen die Knoten 2 und 4 enthalten sein, und du siehst, dass ich nur meinen Schnitt drehen musste, um
diese neuen Punkte einzuschließen – diese Lösung von fünf bleibt gleich
lass uns das Histogramm und die vier wahrscheinlichsten Lösungen kurz genauer betrachten – die letzten beiden Lösungen sind die,
die wir gerade gezeichnet haben, und sie sind gleichermaßen korrekt – aber das ist noch nicht alles: wir könnten auch die Färbung aller
korrekten Lösungen umkehren, und diesmal denken wir uns die Knoten einfach als innerhalb bzw. außerhalb des Schnitts – auf der
vorherigen Folie haben wir zwei eindeutige korrekte Lösungen identifiziert, aber tatsächlich gibt es noch zwei weitere Lösungen, die jeweils
das Gegenteil von jenen darstellen – sieh, wie ich hier die verbleibenden zwei Lösungen gezeichnet habe: ich habe nur die
Farben umgekehrt – das einzige Problem ist nun, dass der Algorithmus diese vierte letzte Lösung tatsächlich nicht als
eine der vier wahrscheinlichsten Antworten gefunden oder identifiziert hat – sie war die fünfte – die vierte Lösung, die der Algorithmus identifiziert hat,
ist tatsächlich falsch, und wenn du sie zeichnen würdest, würdest du sehen, dass diese Lösung nur vier Schnitte hat – da die anderen
fünf haben und vier eindeutig weniger als fünf ist, ist das offensichtlich falsch – der Punkt hier
ist, dass dies ein Näherungsalgorithmus ist – er ist nicht unfehlbar und nicht 100 % der Zeit korrekt – du musst
dein eigenes Wissen und Verständnis einsetzen, um die Lösungen auf Plausibilität zu prüfen – es lohnt sich hervorzuheben, dass
dieser Fehler aus verschiedenen Quellen stammen kann: er könnte auf die Näherungsnatur des Algorithmus selbst zurückzuführen sein sowie auf die geringe
Anzahl von Schichten, die ich gewählt habe – es könnte ein endlicher Stichprobenfehler sein, der sich verringern ließe, wenn ich die
Anzahl der Shots in meinem Experiment erhöhe – oder es könnte ein Auslesefehler sein, da die vierte echte Lösung nur um eins
Bit abweicht – der Grund, warum ich all diese Möglichkeiten anspreche, ist, dass dies erforderlich ist, um wirklich ein
Praktiker des Quantencomputings zu werden – du musst die Leistung der Hardware verstehen und wissen, wie diese dazu beitragen kann,
bestimmte Arten von Fehlern zu verursachen, und wie man sie korrigiert – vergessen wir jedoch nicht, dass
es 32 mögliche Bitstring-Lösungen gab und dass die vier echten Lösungen unter den fünf besten
Kandidaten enthalten waren – und ich habe dafür nur zwei Schichten verwendet – wenn ich generell meine Chancen erhöhen möchte, den
besten Max-Cut jedes Mal zu finden, würde ich die Schichttiefe erhöhen – es gibt einige Feinheiten dabei, aber das ist für eine spätere
Episode – jetzt werde ich dich selbst ausprobieren lassen – aber diesmal wirst du 100
qubits verwenden – wenn wir also mit dem Zeichnen unseres 100-qubit-Graphen beginnen, siehst du, dass es nicht mehr einfach oder überhaupt möglich ist,
auf Anhieb zu erkennen, wo der Max-Cut auftreten würde – es gibt einfach zu viele Möglichkeiten, um ihn von Hand herauszulesen – aber
dieses Problem mit QAOA zu lösen ist immer noch absolut machbar, und du kannst genau denselben Arbeitsablauf verwenden, den wir für 5
qubits genutzt haben – ich schicke dich jetzt auf eigene Faust los und beauftrage dich damit, dieses Experiment durchzuführen – aber bevor ich das tue, lass uns
zusammenfassen: die sechs Schritte eines jeden QAOA-Jobs sind wie folgt – erstens: Definition
eines Cost-Hamiltonians, sodass sein Grundzustand die Lösung des Optimierungsproblems kodiert – zweitens: Definition eines
Mixer-Hamiltonians – drittens: Konstruktion der Operatoren, die den exponierten
Hamiltonians entsprechen – viertens: Aufbau des circuit – er besteht aus dem anfänglichen Grundzustand des Mixers sowie abwechselnden
wiederholten Schichten der Kostenfunktion und der Evolution unter den Mixer-Hamiltonians – fünftens: Vorbereitung eines Anfangszustands und
Verwendung klassischer Rechentechniken zur Optimierung der Parameter – sechstens: Ausführen des circuit, Messen der Ausgabe-Bitstrings
und Suchen nach der wahrscheinlichsten Lösung – einige Dinge sind hier zu beachten:
ich habe Optimierungsstufe drei für mein 5-qubit-Beispiel verwendet, aber das war vielleicht nicht nötig – die richtige Antwort könnte
auch bei einer niedrigeren Optimierungsstufe die meiste Zeit zurückgegeben werden, da die circuit-Tiefe für den 5-
qubit-Fall ziemlich gering war – aber für die 100 qubits und eine große circuit-Tiefe wirst du mit ziemlicher Sicherheit die höchste Optimierungsstufe
benötigen, um die richtige Antwort zu finden – beachte auch, dass einer der schwierigsten Teile eines typischen Utility-
Scale-Workflows die Mapping-Phase ist und das Finden eines Graphen, der gut zu IBMs Heavy-Hex-Topologie passt – wenn du
diese Arbeit von Grund auf neu durchführen würdest, wäre das zweifellos der Teil, dem du den Großteil deiner Zeit widmen würdest – für jetzt wurde dieser Teil
für dich erledigt, da das nicht der Hauptpunkt dieser Übung ist – aber denk daran, dass es etwas ist, das wir
üben werden – und das Ausführen eines groß angelegten Jobs ist nicht immer unkompliziert – wir werden das
in Episode 4 weiter vertiefen – dein endgültiger circuit wird offensichtlich viel unübersichtlicher aussehen als der circuit, der auf 5 qubits lief
– andererseits finde ich es beeindruckend, diesen circuit zu betrachten und zu sehen, wie viele gates er hat, und zu wissen, dass du
die Fähigkeit hast, das tatsächlich auf echten Quantenprozessoren auszuführen – das ist wirklich
beeindruckend – und das war meine endgültige Lösung: du siehst, dass der Algorithmus definitiv in der Lage ist, diese
Knoten in zwei Gruppen einzuteilen und dabei angeblich den besten Max-Cut zu identifizieren, der sie in zwei Mengen teilt – der Übergang von den zwei Mengen
zur Max-Cut-Linie selbst ist trivial: überall dort, wo die Farbe entlang der Linien, die die Knoten verbinden, wechselt,
legt fest, wo die Max-Cut-Linie gezogen werden soll – als ich es ausführte, war der Max-Cut-Wert, den ich erzielen konnte,
84 – versuch es also selbst und schreib mir in den Kommentaren, ob du etwas Ähnliches bekommst – probier drei Schichten, vielleicht vier – versuch,
die Gewichte zwischen den Knoten zu ändern, und schau, wie das das Ergebnis verändert – es gibt viele interessante Experimente,
die wir mit QAOA durchführen können – denk jetzt daran: es ist nicht garantiert, dass ich gerade die bestmögliche
Lösung gefunden habe – wir wissen, dass es eine gute Lösung ist – aber zum Spaß fordere ich dich heraus, mich zu schlagen – schau, ob du etwas
bekommst, das besser als 84 ist – abschließend lässt sich sagen, dass QAOA ein sehr dynamischer
Algorithmus ist und es viele Heuristiken und noch vieles zu erforschen gibt – er bietet viel Raum, um neue
Dinge über das Optimierungsfeld im Allgemeinen zu lernen – es wurde zuletzt viel Arbeit im Optimierungsbereich geleistet,
wie die vielen Archiv-Paper belegen, die kürzlich online über QAOA oder Optimierung veröffentlicht wurden – und was
wirklich cool ist: schließlich sind nicht alle diese Paper Theorie-Paper – Theoretiker haben QAOA
jahrelang studiert – aber jetzt werden auch die Experimentatoren einbezogen, weil wir endlich die Hardware haben
– wie IBMs Prozessoren –, die in der Lage ist, viele dieser Experimente durchzuführen – wir bewegen uns vom Vorstellungsraum
in die reale Welt, und das ist sehr aufregend – ja, es gibt noch viel zu tun, und es gibt immer noch
viele Fehler, mit denen wir umgehen müssen – aber wir machen schnelle Fortschritte, und du, der du dieses
Video schaust und es bis hierhin geschafft hast, bist in der Lage, diese Experimente selbst durchzuführen – geh und versuch, dein eigenes
100-qubit-Experiment durchzuführen, und lass uns wissen, wie es gelaufen ist – folge dem Tutorial, dann bist du in guten Händen – und wenn du
Fragen hast oder nicht weiterkommst, mach dir keine Sorgen – wir alle haben das so gefühlt oder hatten dieselben Fragen, als wir anfingen,
das zu lernen – gib dein Bestes, lass uns wissen, welche Fragen dir begegnen, und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal
[Musik]